Republicans in 2023 and the American
right-wing movement is fundamentally
about we are the victims and about
grievances even though the right loves
to say all these leftists are constantly
making themselves the victims be it of
racial bias or gender bias or whatever
the case may be it is actually we on the
right who are truly the victims and one
of the big Avenues during which they've
through which they've claimed this
victim victimhood is through big Tech
Twitter is de-prioritizing our content
um uh ideas that are simply questioning
the status quo and conventional wisdom
of covet vaccines are being shut down
and we are being silenced and blah blah
blah blah and even though they love to
say these left Wingers got to stop with
the Grievances and with the word we are
the victims it is really the right that
has played that card and the most
interesting aspect of it is that every
time it's been tested
every time it's been investigated every
time it's been looked into in some
detail it turns out that it is actually
not true Republicans latest ridiculous
claim is against Google and it is a
claim of bias and it has been debunked
they tried to say that Google spam
filters in Gmail were biased against
conservatives the idea was the spam
filter is not merely making a a an
impartial analysis of what should be
redirected to your spam folder it is
using partisanship whereas repub wherein
Republican fundraising emails are much
more likely to end up in spam than
Democratic fundraising emails emails
from the RNC
are much more likely to end up in spam
than emails from the DNC and it has now
been studied by the FEC and the
determination that's been made is that's
just not the case and of course the
right is outraged the right says that
the analysis itself is biased but the
truth is that whenever these things are
looked into we are unable to find
evidence of bias in the investigation
and the investigation is unable to find
evidence of bias in the underlying
phenomena which they are looking at the
FEC looked into it and determined that
it was not true now this is not actually
surprising and it's not surprising in
two different ways it's not surprising
when it comes to the RNC
and it's not surprising when it comes to
Google and I'll deal with each of those
aspects one by one the RNC and the
Republican party and right Wingers and
Maga you know whatever all of them they
have been grasping at straws trying to
prove big Tech has a liberal bias and
the truth is that that has not been
determined to be the case when you
looked at I mean just go through it one
by one when there was an analysis done
of Twitter it turned out that that was
not the case if you by the way now that
Elon Musk has taken over Twitter there's
this new thing called the for you feed
it's basically a sort of algorithmically
curated feed not based on it's not the
the people you follow
it's sort of like a stuff you might be
interested in it's just right-wing trash
I went on there and it was Carrie Lake
anti-vax coveted skeptical stuff uh uh
the the left is censoring what about
whoa good anti-woke anti-trans it was
crazy okay so Twitter wasn't found to be
the case especially not now under Elon
Musk leadership it's become a right-wing
uh platform Facebook well supposedly
Facebook is very much biased against the
right they so they claimed then an
analysis was done every single week
including leading up to the election
after the election well before the the
elections 2020 2022 the best performing
content on Facebook is almost
exclusively right-wing content Dan
bongino Ben Shapiro all these types of
people every once in a while there's a
um Rachel Maddow clip that makes it in
there the top stuff on Facebook is right
wing stuff
now Gmail okay
um so it's not surprising and this idea
that there's just constant liberal bias
in all big Tech has been disproven time
and time again the RNC made the claims
about Twitter before Elon Musk bought it
it was dismissed Etc now
um there's another aspect to this
Republicans are trying to make
campaigning against big Tech a big part
of their election strategy because again
they are the party of victimhood they
are the the grievance politics people
and it may still work like it doesn't
actually matter if they can keep
campaigning on big Tech is biased
against us it might still be useful to
them but then we get to the Google part
listen
I am no generic defender of Google I
mean I just in the same way that I'm no
generic defender of any platform but
having spam filters that are biased
against conservatives would not be in
Google's interests in any way Google is
a business its primary goal is to make
money and alienating a large segment of
the population through such partisan
spam filtering or even if it's not overt
but if campaigns don't convert
and these right Wingers start to realize
it's Gmail that's preventing the
campaigns from converting by sending our
emails into spam it wouldn't be good for
Google's business it wouldn't be good
for Gmail's business so there's really
no reason that they would do it uh and
so it doesn't make sense on any level
and it's time I hope for the RNC to move
on from these conspiracy theories and
from the Grievances and from the
victimization focus on real issues there
are things you could do
as the Republican party to maybe
actually convince some people to vote
for you based on based on good ideas
rather than just more Grievances and
more complaining and more whining but
once again it's been studied it's been
debunked and of course they will say the
study itself was biased hey you have to
see this uh the Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton says he is willing and able
to defend a law that bans gay sex in
private now these are sometimes referred
to as sodomy laws and obviously if you
are a small government conservative the
first thing you would do is start trying
to pass laws about what people can do in
the privacy of their own bedroom no
that's not at all what you would do but
it is a tired example of how the values
they state are not the actual values
they espouse when it is no longer
convenient to them it is absurd and
terrifying that Ken Paxton is saying hey
let's look at ways to roll back LGBT
rights I mean the fact that that's
happening even in some general sense is
horrifying we may be naively hoped in
2015 after the gay marriage decision
that we were all moving beyond these
issues of trying to limit the rights of
LGBT people that we have seen from the
right we very quickly realized they're
not giving up they're just going to
shift the battle lines they shifted from
gay marriage to for example religious
freedom
to discriminate against gay people
uh bathroom stuff Trend you you all know
this stuff so now we hear from Ken
Paxton I have a clip here uh he is of
course always couching this as States
should get to decide
what types of sex people can have
in their bedroom but we're not falling
for it take a look at this uh would you
as attorney general be comfortable
defending a law that once again outlawed
sodomy Lawrence again or Griswold uh or
gay marriage uh that came from the state
legislature to to put to the test what
Justice Thomas said
yeah I mean there's all kinds of issues
here but certainly the Supreme Court has
stepped into issues that I don't think
there was any constitutional provision
dealing with they were legislative
issues wow and this is one of those
issues and there may be more so
understand the gist of what he is saying
because these guys are pretty damn good
at using euphemism and talking around
issues what Ken Paxton fundamentally is
saying is that the Supreme Court has
overstepped the same way that they say
well the Supreme Court overstepped on
gay marriage the Supreme Court
overstepped on Roe v Wade which they've
since been able to get rolled back and
they say States should get to decide
these things but at the end of the day
this is very much like those who say the
Civil War was not about slavery it was
about states rights ah but it was not
about states rights to determine we're
going to use the inch or the centimeter
right it was about states rights to
determine they want to continue making
it legal to own people and force them to
do work for you as slaves and very much
the same way what Ken Paxton is saying
here is I can very much defend the laws
in which Texas might ban gay sex in the
privacy of bedrooms and make it a crime
which is insanely overreaching for
government especially for people
claiming that they are small government
conservatives he's not going to say it
that way he's gonna say we believe it
can be defended because the Supreme
Court has overreached in certain ways
Beyond Where We Believe
it's a very clear indication that Paxton
and other so-called conservatives are
not only comfortable but are actively
working and interested in rolling back
lgtb LGBT rights we said that this would
happen uh right after the Roe v Wade
decision it is a disgusting violation of
Human Rights it's a step towards more
discrimination towards more oppression
and it goes against their own stated
principles and the fact that Paxton is
willing to publicly come out and say
discriminatory disgusting oppressive law
well we're going to defend states rights
because that's my job under the
Constitution it shows either or both he
doesn't actually understand what it
means to have rights or
he assumes the people who support him
don't
and that's much the way that Fox News
operates like I don't literally think
Fox News hosts believe a lot of the crap
they say but they believe Their audience
will believe it and they're mostly
correct and that has been much of Ken
Paxton and in general the Texas governor
and Lieutenant Governor's Mo which is we
will assume our voters don't know the
difference and this stuff will sound
pretty damn good to them so
extraordinarily dangerous whether Paxton
is actually going to fight to again ban
certain types of sex in people's private
homes between consenting adults I don't
know I'm hoping it doesn't actually get
to that point but he's certainly saying
all the things that make us think that's
what's coming make sure you're
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
what a week of programs we have for you
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
Donald Trump was soaking wet and
slurring badly in a bizarre funeral
promotion now you might say David what
what do you mean a funeral promotion
like an ad for a funeral yes things have
gotten I dare say kafka-esque in the
aftermath of the tragic passing of
diamond of the dynamic pro-trump duo
diamond and silk you may recall that
diamond recently died
believed to be from covid although I
still don't know if it's been confirmed
this was a pro-trump group of group two
women very very much pro-trump spreaders
of anti-vaccine disinformation uh
spreaders of all sorts of different
misinformation in fact I should say
Donald Trump announced that he will be
presiding over the funeral of diamond in
North Carolina over the weekend he is
soaking wet all almost dripping he is
slurring extraordinarily badly but the
strangest part of it might be
why are you advertising a funeral it's
an unusual thing look at this and
remember folks this is not a parody this
is real listen please join us on
Saturday January Saturday
21st in Fayetteville North Carolina she
loved that state and so do I as we
celebrate the life of diamond
she lived it in a credible way and we're
going to have a wonderful celebration
and ceremony
all of diamonds families and silk we
love silk her sisters she loved her
sister so much and they loved each other
and they really loved the world
they were with me from the beginning and
they never wavered
so we're going to celebrate silk we'll
be there but I'll be there and we're
going to celebrate the life of diamond
see you in North Carolina
are they going to celebrate I I'm having
Trump only mentioned it four times I
guess they're going to celebrate there
why is he soaking wet why is he slurring
but the the wackiest part of this is
he's promoting a funeral in a very
strange way and and maybe this the
silliest part of this entire thing is
you know when I think of people needing
Comfort people really needing someone
who knows in difficult times just
exactly what to say to really provide
that comfort
it's hard to think of a worse person to
deliver that than than Donald Trump
truly and it would not surprise me if
Trump didn't even know which one was
diamond and which was silk and there are
really a maybe the other thing to talk
about here before we move on to clips
from the actual eulogy which but listen
if you
Trump giving a eulogy okay it's going to
be absolutely crazy and we will get to
that there is an irony in a sense
of trump speaking at the funeral of
diamond who was a vocal supporter of
Trump's presidency and his failed
campaign and all of it
given Trump's endlessly divisive
rhetoric and treatment of the black
community that's at the end of the day
one of these issues that continues to
rear its ugly head when when you you
look at a situation like diamond and
silk or blacks for Trump or whatever the
case may be the ability of and again I
don't know if it's like seeing past what
Trump actually is and was with regard to
many of these communities or an
indifference or a deliberate ignoring of
it for personal gain because diamond and
silk got a ton of publicity and and
became known as a result of their
support of trump
um I don't know what it is but that is
really the irony of all of it and as you
can imagine
Trump as out of place at a black church
during a during a funeral for a black
woman as you can imagine and we're going
to talk about that next
failed former president Donald Trump in
one of his most cartoonishly bizarre
acts gave I guess you would call it a
eulogy at the funeral service of diamond
of diamond and silk her real name was
not Diamond it was anethia Lynette
Hardaway she passed away not long ago
believed to be from covid unvaccinated
we'll get to that by the way a little
bit later Donald Trump announced in a
soaking wet and slurring statement as we
looked at earlier that he would be
presiding over it Donald Trump did not
know that this was going to go for three
hours and in fact he ended up
complaining about it but let's start
with Trump's heartwarming and emotional
tribute to Diamond
saying the prisons of many countries are
emptying out into the United States the
mental institutions of many countries
are emptying out into the United States
talk about gas prices and inflation not
a typical eulogy as one would expect you
know things we can fix inflation we can
fix so much of what's been damaged over
the last two years we had it going so
well but we can fix these things but you
know millions of people I think 15
million people they say three maybe four
I don't know I think remember a memorial
service remembering the great Diamond
this is what Trump is talking about
they have no idea how many people
and they allowed their prisons to be
emptied out into the United States of
America they allowed their mental
institutions to be emptied out into the
United States of America never happened
Common Sense would tell you that if you
had common sense you wouldn't be doing
that
Mike would know that but you wouldn't be
doing this by the way Trump's pointing
to Mike pillow millions and millions of
people are coming and no country would
be able to withstand this no country
whether you're rich or poor and we're
not really rich we owe as of this
morning 31 trillion dollars right so I
don't know you call it rich I guess I
don't know maybe not this is really
helping me to mourn and grieve with the
diamonds family we spend a lot of money
on other countries and many of those
countries hate us so we give them money
so common sense would tell you all of
these things inflation was caused by
energy they stopped the energy and all
of a sudden you gasoline went from 1.87
a gallon two five six seven in
California eight dollars a gallon and
when you Baker makes his cakes and when
your hospitals create heat and all of
the different things you need this for
everything goes up and it's run away
it's far greater than people thought
this this is this is performance art I
mean uh in in a thousand years when
future sociologists and anthropologists
and psychologists want to learn about
the insanity of this era you would show
them this and you would say this was a
funeral eulogy for a woman who died
and died at a relatively young age
and this was a former president who
showed up and talked about mental
institutions so-called being emptied out
into our country Trump then complained
as he often does he was not expecting
this to go more than three hours okay
and he was not particularly happy and
and I don't believe you know they told
me he said give me a little time because
I have a lot of people waiting for me
back in a place called Palm Beach
Florida
they said give me a little time what do
you think it'll take oh about 15-20
minutes in and out
I said what could take longer this is a
little longer than 15 minutes right
yes it was I mean it is true it was
three plus hours of stories and prayers
and hymns is that how you pronounce it
hymns the N Asylum
um and it took a very very long time and
Donald Trump was not particularly
pleased with that Donald Trump also
announcing to the crowd again this is
all in memory of diamond it's all out of
respect for her memory and her life and
everything Trump announcing he wanted to
ensure that there would be valet parking
at their valet service at this event
please know that we share in your grief
that's why you have such an incredible
crowd of people I said let's pick a big
place I don't care don't worry about it
just pick a big place
because uh the Trump's not paying anyway
so who cares right he'll just not pay
Apple wouldn't have held the kind of
people the number of people that we have
and uh we're doing it right and that's
the way it should be and I did notice a
big line of very very uh nice Vehicles
outside that's going to be handled
properly right so we're going to handle
it properly go out and style she knew
that go out and style folks we will be
remembering The Life and Times of
diamond and we will share in the grief
and and tragedy with her family and a
valet will be properly handling all cars
please make sure to tip make sure to tip
the valet and then just when you thought
the eulogy could not get any stranger
Trump decides to make it about himself
and with tears and tissues in the crowd
he concludes this moving tribute by
reminding the crowd that the 2020
election was stolen from him how do we
stop the cheating how do we stop it
where you get more votes but you still
don't win and the answer is the
Republicans have to get tougher yeah the
top people have to get tougher right and
and you have to really swap them there's
a level at which even they can't produce
and so if you win big enough you're
going to get there and then once we're
there we're going to straighten it all
out and get it back to where it was but
yeah
um Saturday Night Live could do nothing
with this because this is already like
part 20 of a Saturday Night Live skit
unbelievable unbelievable it's it's a
sort of Genius parody avant-garde
performance uh art of some way it's
kafka-esque it's delusional it's
hilarious it's sad it's a tragic comedy
um unbelievable and listen Trump
deserves some credit in the sense that
it was hard to imagine even Trump
turning this event into something so
absurd and unable to be parodied but he
was able to do it now let's move on to
the shedding vaccine conspiracy that
came from this event all right so after
consistently speaking out against
vaccinations for years and years and
years
silk of diamond and silk remember
diamond is alethea Lynette Hardaway who
recently died we believe of covid
unvaccinated
silk is now suggesting that diamond died
because of the vaccine I actually had to
look at the clip I'm going to play for
you a bunch of times to figure out even
what was the conspiracy theory that Silk
is putting out there initially I said
well how did Diamond die of the vaccine
because remember they didn't seem to be
vaccinated this was what they said about
the vaccine yes we don't need
don't need the community right but what
we don't need to happen is what happened
with Africa right when Bill Gates in
them took that vaccine to Africa yeah to
vaccinate they felt like stuff can start
right there in certain parts of of
Africa that's what we don't need to
you're not gonna make black people not
the guinea pig
no uh yo yo project not black yes today
Billy yes the surgeon the Surgeon
General was talking to as a matter of
fact he was trending today listen I I
tell us what we need to know yeah but I
always look at the underbelly of what's
going on that's the intuition in me yeah
so needless to say their intuition LED
them not to be vaccinated so then we go
to the memorial service here is silk
eulogizing Diamond I had to listen a
bunch of times but I believe what she's
saying here is Diamond was poisoned by
coming into contact with vaccinated
people other people having been
vaccinated
killed Diamond by the way she says this
with Trump there sitting four feet away
who takes credit for the vaccines are
Americans being poisoned
uh-huh
and the wow
when they want to depopulate and
sterilize a large group of animals
they usually inject one animal right and
then that one animal in fact the rest of
the animals oof so technically and
according to the science oh it doesn't
matter it's your vast or not ah
as long as the gain of function allows
one injected person to transfer and
affect another person and that person
affect another person eventually
everyone will be affected in one way or
the other Now understand
she's not talking it's you would hear
that and say oh she's describing how a
virus spreads all right like one person
gets infected and then the next and the
next the next no no no no
she's talking about the vaccine and
what's amazing is Trump's vaccinated and
he's sitting four feet away if you
believe this does silk really believe
this I have no idea I really couldn't
tell you if silk really believes this
then Trump's presence there is a major
danger to everybody who's in the crowd
because Trump would be shedding vaccine
or whatever now we've talked about this
many times before this concept of
shedding vaccine is the idea that if
you're vaccinated you can spread there's
different versions there's you're
vaccinated you can spread the virus by
shedding it out of the vaccine not
possible because the coveted vaccine
doesn't have active virus in it that's
not possible or you're vaccinated and
you're shedding vaccine now that's not
true all that would happen is maybe
other people would end up vaccinated but
that's not actually what happens the
coveted vaccines don't contain live Iris
it's impossible it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen
how insane is this at the we believe
that diamond died of coven
we as far as we know they are not
vaccinated and silk starts doing the
conspiracy theory that diamond may have
been poisoned by vaccinated people I
guess shooting particles of the vaccine
all around them like a cloud of sorts
these are very very sick people and
there we don't I don't minimize or
dismiss their grief
by any means but even in their grief
they continue to actively do damage to
the world that chooses to follow science
and empiricism and Common Sense and try
to act in ways where we are sort of
trying to help those around us very very
sad and there are four or five different
tragedies all all together here not just
that we believe Diamond died of covet
unvaccinated but there's a bunch of
other tragedies here as well we'll have
all of these clips that I played for you
on our Instagram you can find us on
Instagram it's quite intuitive in fact
you just search for David packman show
on Instagram you'll find all of these
clips you can also find them on our
YouTube channel at youtube.com slash the
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
everybody I hate that I have to do this
video but after more than two weeks I
don't have a choice anymore because our
YouTube channel is quite frankly on the
verge of death uh you know I know that
haters joke about David you're you're
circling the drain and all of this stuff
quite frankly as far as the YouTube
channel is concerned
things look absolutely terrible right
now I was hoping that this would resolve
and that I wouldn't even come to you
with this as a big strong guy right uh
but it's getting worse something has
happened and our videos are no longer
being recommended to viewers in the way
that for years and years they were now
you will notice there are no conspiracy
theories here or irresponsible
speculation it's me telling you the
facts and the numbers and then giving
the most charitable hypothesis about
what happened we have 1.6 million
subscribers on YouTube and there are now
videos that are sometimes getting 2 000
views now I know my haters will say
David that's because your videos suck
well some of them may suck okay I won't
I won't deny that but as a sheer
mathematical reality with 1.6 million
subscribers
our videos would never get 2 000 views
even a bad video was fifteen thousand
twenty thousand views here's the story
on January 9th mysteriously there was a
roughly six to seven hour period during
which our live analytics showed almost
no views like not few views but just
almost zero and we're putting that up on
the screen as little as like 1900 views
in an entire hour during a time of day
where we'd normally have a hundred
thousand views in an hour or even more
this impacted our Channel and others our
channel was not the only one impacted by
this some of uh our colleagues in
left-wing politics were impacted by this
and people outside of politics were
impacted by this fine YouTube told us
your views are fine this is just a
reporting glitch so this is sort of like
you know if a smoke detector goes off
it might go off because there's smoke
but it might go off because the smoke
detector is broken it's malfunctioning
we were told the views are fine fine
the next day things were supposedly
fixed after three or four days some
slightly higher numbers were replaced in
our analytics for that six seven hour
period on January 9th but I could
immediately tell that views were dead
subscribers were flat one day we even
lost subscribers after gaining
subscribers every day for years we
actually lost three subscribers net one
day and since January 9th the channel
has been dead
there are videos that after 90 minutes
after two hours have 2 000 or fewer
views we're putting that up on the
screen for you to take a look at again
this is something that just hasn't
happened in years and you do the math
with 1.6 million subscribers it just
doesn't pass the sniff test views
Revenue are down 60 or 70 percent
subscribers are at a crawl now this is
happening to many channels of people
that you know I'm not going to mention
them it's not appropriate if they choose
to talk about what's going on that's
absolutely fine for them to do however
it is not affecting all of our channels
there are some creators in news and
politics whose channels are doing
absolutely fine now I genuinely have no
idea what is happening but I have some
speculations okay
I am not claiming at this time that
anybody at YouTube did anything
malicious I am not claiming at this time
that YouTube made a decision let's screw
over David Pacman and a bunch of these
other creators I don't have the evidence
to say that so that is not my hypothesis
at this point in time so something took
us completely out of the recommendation
algorithm I even notice it when browsing
YouTube on my personal account uh not
connected to the David Pacman show
channel I used to get my own videos
recommended they are completely gone
here is one of dozens and dozens of
emails from viewers explaining this Tom
Rhoden and said
I exclusively scroll through the
recently uploaded YouTube category but
other categories are likely populated by
similar algorithmic logic I noticed a
month or two ago I stopped seeing your
videos recommended I had to manually
search for your channel to find it this
also happened with some of my other
favorite creators all of those in your
channel have one thing in common I
started to ignore those videos on
YouTube because I watched them on other
platforms patreon Etc since then I've
noticed that whatever Channel I click on
in recently uploaded has a massive
impact on what is recommended in the
future dozens of emails like that I am
going to give you the most innocent
explanation okay the most innocent
explanation is there was this glitch on
January 9th and it heard us during that
six hour period but it then caused
something to happen
which led to no engagement maybe it was
a period during which our videos didn't
come up as recommended for people
anymore whatever it was it became a
vicious cycle and it told YouTube no
one's clicking David's videos so stop
recommending them all together
that's not me saying someone did it
I don't know but it is what happened so
right now we have to see if we can fix
this I need you to help me with super
simple tasks that cost nothing okay we
need to try to re-engineer our way into
the algorithm if this doesn't work it
will be a really good piece of data
about what might be going on now if it
works that's absolutely fantastic so
here's what I would ask you to do I
believe if a few thousand people do this
it may fix the problem first do a search
for David Pacman on YouTube and click on
one of our videos do it a second time do
it a third time the key is search for
David pakman click on the videos which
will train the algorithm this is what
people are looking for when you click
onto my videos
please make sure you are subscribed
please please please and make sure after
subscribing that you click the Bell
and select all this tells YouTube Not
only am I subscribed I want to see
David's videos in my feed
please like the video and if you can
please leave a comment now ideally if
YouTube then shows you more of my videos
and the recommendations either to the
side or below the video you're watching
click another one of my videos ideally
like it comment the idea is string back
to back videos of mine together which is
hopefully training the YouTube algorithm
this is the this is the path people are
actually looking for now if you don't
get any recommendations for my videos if
you only get Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy
Kimmel and other people named Jimmy
search for me again click like comment
now
if this entire thing is nothing
nefarious and we simply fell out of the
algorithm just several hundred or
ideally a couple of thousand of you out
of the 1.6 million subscribers and some
non-subscribers doing this
this might fix the problem completely
and resolve it if it doesn't then it'll
be really useful information and
whatever's going on is even worse than
we thought now the other part YouTube
revenue is down 60 to 70 percent
we count on that we're counting on using
that money to launch the Spanish Channel
we are very close to launching a dubbed
to Spanish version of our channel to hit
the Spanish-speaking Community dubbing
is really really expensive really really
expensive thousands of dollars per month
we were counting on the revenue from the
main channel to fund the dubbing on the
Spanish channel so this is a very bad
time for this to be happening please
grab a membership at joinpakman.com okay
it's really cheap you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now you'll get a sizable
discount pay full price or not whatever
we just need to supplement 60 to 70
percent is a big big big big big deal so
let's do it let's give this 48 hours and
then I will report back to you whether
this did anything at all anything at all
to deal with this algorithmic issue that
we are experiencing and if it doesn't
then it will give us more information
and we can go from there
I want to talk to you today about comedy
and sheltered people and completely
screwed up senses of humor one of the
most interesting psychological and
cultural phenomena that we can look at
right now is what right-wingers think is
funny now we've talked about before how
when right-wingers have tried to do
satirical news it just like doesn't work
and part of it is you can't really tell
the difference from actual right-wing
news because it's all so dumb and stupid
and shows like the half hour news hour
on Fox News failed you know you've got
this guy Greg Gutfeld on Fox News who I
guess is a comedian you can't tell when
he's doing a comedy bit and when he's
being serious he right-wing comedy just
it doesn't really work in a normal way
I am now going to present to you sort of
the latest edition of what the hell are
these people thinking I bring you today
a clip from this reawaken America Tour
these are these events that are held in
uh sort of like circus tents that are
kind of like churches all over the place
many of these are affiliated with
Christian hate preacher Greg Locke they
brought in comedian Jim Brewer Jim
Brewer is now I guess you can call him a
right-wing comedian and what is amazing
to me is he mocks flu shots he mocks
vaccines he seems to mock Demar Hamlin
the NFL player who recently suffered a
cardiac arrest on on the field and
thankfully is is moving ahead in his
recovery and the crowd just loves it the
this is comedy to these people and it is
extraordinarily sad in terms of what it
says about our country take a look at
this still have my in-laws my in-laws
are like we gotta get our flu shot then
a booster
done another booster
this guy's clapping this guy isn't he's
in stitches folks if you're listening
there's a Vietnam veteran hat wearing
guy
who is just clapping he's he's he's so
uh he's he's almost apoplectic in
laughter
starting to die where'd you hear that
right
Woody one of those conspiracy theorists
whoa
the left had better be ready for this
because the right is starting to get
good at comedy look at these young
ladies who were just overcome with
laughter
[Music]
[Laughter]
well you're a cult member
extremists winning
I guess this is an imitation of a left
Winger that Jim Brewer is doing I don't
know
[Laughter]
so I guess the joke he falls down Jim
Brewer throws himself down on the ground
like like a tantruming two-year-old I
guess the joke is oh everything's fine
with the vaccines oh whoops Demar Hamlin
is now down on the ground
I think the joke is that the vaccine
caused what happened to Demar Hamlin of
course for which there's no evidence I
again I'm trying to interpret stuff that
is unintelligible I believe that's the
joke to the extent that it's a joke that
Jim Brewer is making
and that really gets the crowd right
riled up
[Applause]
isn't this great guys
[Music]
crazy conspiracy theorist
all right so then the same then the same
bit just starts over again only the most
sheltered people would find this stuff
funny
if
you are if you if your entertainment
and your thinking is mostly watching
paint dry
maybe this is funny because Brewers
making you know like a silly face but
it's disturbing and it's pathetic and
it's really disheartening to see what is
considered funny these days among the
right and these Trends we mock vaccines
and we mock people who get them and we
mock doctors and you know the last time
we talked about Jim Brewer about a year
ago he was making fun of people who
listened to doctors but even Brewer
himself when his wife was was very sick
I forget what with I think it was a type
of cancer he wasn't mocking doctors then
or Specialists or any of it he found the
best people and he went to them and he
listened to them so that he could
actually get treatment so even Brewer
this may even be an act as far as Brewer
is concerned but it reveals this deep
ignorance this deep lack of empathy
towards struggles that people have
towards people affected by the pandemic
people healthcare workers
and on and on and on but it's also a
reflection of a larger problem within
the right wing and this increased
tendency to retreat into their Echo
Chambers because this is now no longer
even just well different news sources
and different underlying beliefs about
ABCD issue this this is about we are
going to surround ourselves with people
so delusionally like-minded that it
becomes an impossibility to ever break
out of this right if you're laughing
this hard as hard as this woman is
laughing at the act that Jim Brewer is
doing I don't know how you ever get out
of that Echo chamber and I don't know
how how our society can actually move
forward in any kind of constructive
Manner and I hate that I have become so
cynical and negative about this but
I am very NE I'm very pessimistic about
it I mean when you see this laughter
at what I just played for you
uh I I I don't know where we go from
here let me know what you think in the
comments
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
it's quite stunning but not altogether
surprising how quickly the perspectives
on President's present and former having
classified documents uh has changed
given the recent news about Joe Biden
now as a reminder for all the people
emailing me saying David why won't you
talk about the Joe Biden classified
documents we've talked about it so many
times at this point investigate Biden
figure out what happened figure out if
there was wrongdoing but it is a totally
separate case from that of trump and it
doesn't mean you stop investigating
Trump because you're investigating Joe
Biden for a while when it was Donald
Trump who had directed staff to take
hundreds of classified documents to his
house who tried to use lawyers to
prevent giving them back who had his
lawyers say we gave them back even
though they didn't give them back and
everything that led up to the search
warrant being executed at Mar-A-Lago
during all of that time right-wingers
were saying this is a Witch Hunt this is
a paperwork issue this is a non-story
this is just something that happens and
you just deal with it and the documents
you give back and then you just move on
you don't do all of this crazy stuff
including showing up at Trump's house at
Mar-A-Lago but now all of a sudden that
it's Joe Biden being investigated for
something similar but not at all the
same thing all of a sudden now they're
talking about treason I that is not an
exaggeration in this clip I'm going to
play for you Fox News host and Perpetual
Trump brown noser Maria Bartiromo asks
James Comer congressman is this treason
and even Comer isn't ready to go that
far yet take a look we need to know now
who had access to those documents
because our national security could be
at risk Well I this is is this treason
it's it's very concerning uh we're not
going to let up I think that we've got
plenty of information to move forward uh
this would be a lot easier if the White
House would work with us but not only
are they stonewalling our investigation
you know they're they're constantly if
you watch that press conference with the
the Eon Sam who's the guy they brought
in to to fight back against the
investigators which is preposterous
because this is the oversight Community
we're supposed to provide oversight to
the federal government the executive
branch uh you know it's nothing but but
slurs you know they need to work the
American people can see through this the
media is starting to see CNN CBS all
right okay and the music is coming up
very quickly there so up listen was
Maria Bartiromo asking whether it was
treason when it was Trump with hundreds
of documents after months of trying to
keep them right right and I want you to
think really really carefully about this
Biden having a small number of documents
Left Behind from when he was vice
president
which he didn't direct anyone to take
which his lawyers found and immediately
called the National Archives and told
them here's what we found we want to get
it back to you and fully cooperating
with an investigation that might be
treason okay on the other hand Trump
deliberately taking hundreds of
documents to his house using lawyers to
obstruct the investigation not turning
them over that is of course a Witch Hunt
or something the double standard is
breathtaking breathtaking but it is not
altogether surprising and I will again I
know people love to write in and say
David you're so biased on a lot of the I
am on the left without a doubt my views
on issues when it comes to Taxation and
the climate and education My Views are
on the left there's no doubt about it
but I make every effort not to play
these games with you because actually
unlike the fox audience which doesn't
respect Their audience and it's like my
audience is stupid we'll they'll fall
for anything we say I actually respect
you and so I don't play the debt deficit
games I don't play the gas price games
and those parties I I don't do it and
with this issue I have said there are
some relevant important differences
between the Trump and Biden classified
document situations regardless those
differences should come out in
investigations that take place into both
of them so don't play those games with
me
allowing Republican Congressman George
Santos was met with some brutal heckling
brutal heckling at LaGuardia Airport
when he arrived yesterday he faced
questions continuing to face questions
about more of his lies now it turns out
that he appears to have
um you know I I don't know the right
terminology I don't know if he was a
drag queen like I don't know dressed in
drag was a drag queen I don't know what
I do know
is that Republicans for a year have been
saying that drag queens are one of the
greatest threats to America and our
children that they have ever seen from
the left and it turns out George Santos
appears to have also dressed in drag he
seems to be admitting it he's just
saying I was having fun okay we'll get
to the on the bonus show anyway he
arrives at LaGuardia Airport
and is immediately swarmed take a look
at this
I've already told you specifically in DC
that I would sit with you okay if you
approached it throughout the proper
Channel
call my office oh I did they don't write
back to me
look at this
case for you guys right now is that I'm
focusing Services
look at all the work he's doing
who did you speak with
classified classified that's
genius so I I looked into that
um my understanding is that who he meets
with
is not classified it's just private you
know and and this is again these people
have no business in these role it's
classified now you might just not give
us the names of everyone you met with
although it might actually be public
record I don't know
uh look guys I wish you guys were all
I'm gonna go in an elevator I wish you
guys well
young and I had to fun at a festival so
there he is asked about the drag queen
stuff he says I was young and I had fun
assuming for having a life
how about the seven hundred thousand
dollars
was your mother at the World Trade
Center on 911 is related to the fact
that Santos has told two different
stories about when his mother died I
love your guy who keeps following me and
playing
with him good job tipping you guys off
all right so then he gets himself into
an elevator here's a nice one cbs2
talked about this they are now as a
matter of fact just introducing him as a
disgraced Congressman which I have to
tell you I love we begin with breaking
news tonight disgraced Congressman
George Santos he's been he's been in
office a week and they're already
referring to him as disgraced
Congressman back in town our cameras
were there when he landed at LaGuardia
late this afternoon yeah
he ignored many of the questions from
reporters but did say he's working for
his constituents he also criticized the
media I wish you guys well I'm gonna go
and I have spoken with the voters I've
been in District the whole week I've
been taking constituent calls I've
received Federal grant applications for
projects in the district and I look
forward to serving the people the one
thing I'll say is the media and we've
received plenty of complaints about you
guys staking up the embattled lawmaker
is facing more scrutiny over his past
Santos said his mother escaped the south
tower on 9 11 but a researcher obtained
immigration records showing she was in
Brazil at the time yeah anyway
um we are going to have to stay on this
because I I really do fear fear and I'm
increasingly thinking that he is just
going to stick it out no matter how he
accumulating it is he wants to be a big
boy congressman and he is going to just
try to avoid the pressure on him to
resign for now and he may well get away
with it because I'll be honest I don't
know how long like eventually
I think eventually we'll get to the end
of his lies that can be uncovered and so
then it's just recycling stories and
saying we still think he should resign
the story will go away so let us keep
the pressure on media outlets and other
members of Congress to keep the pressure
on Santos but I'm worried that this may
be starting to lose Steam and he may be
able to end up serving those two years
which would be absolutely horrible we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P call anytime 219 to David P
speaking of George Santos here is a
caller asking a very interesting
question about the Santos fiasco
is George Santos was a Democrat how do
you think the situation would be handled
differently do you think that Jeffries
and the Democrats would be
a lot more proactive in in the same
situation where you have a couple seat
advantage
um the Democrats have a couple seed
advantage and it would hurt their
majority and their amount of power I do
now you know this is one of those things
where when I feel that Republicans and
Democrats are basically the same I will
tell you and when I think they're
different I will tell you one of the
things that Democrats do to a fault is
they are in their effort to show
how they will not simply stand by any
Democrat no matter what sometimes
Democrats are too quick to condemn their
own a great example is the Al Franken
situation Al Franken involved in a
tasteless joke that was photographed but
what Al Franken did in retrospect
probably was not worthy of a resignation
and Al Franken resigned because there
was pressure on him to resign Anthony
Weiner Democrats abandoned him if George
Santos were a Democrat I believe there
is no doubt if he had told these lies
and about these issues that he the
pressure on him to resign would have
been total from the Democratic party and
that he would have ultimately ended up
resigning maybe to the detriment of
Democrats that is the way I have seen
Democrats operate over the last decade
in American politics so if you disagree
with me let me know but I think it would
have been handled completely differently
and Santos would be gone if he were a
Democrat and the same things were
uncovered we have such a great bonus
show for you today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah
um on the bonus show today it has been
determined by a judge that Ron DeSantis
violated the first amendment by removing
an elected official who was that
official I will tell you uh what we've
talked about it before we will talk
about the George Santos drag photo story
because it is a story about hypocrisy
it's a story about supposed values that
they don't really care about on the
right it's a very interesting story and
by the way I couldn't care less who's a
drag queen doesn't make a difference to
me it's the hypocrisy that is
interesting to me and we have a
Challenger for Kirsten Cinema former
David Pacman show guest Reuben Gallego
is running against Kirsten Cinema for
Senate in Arizona we will talk about
what is on the table what this means for
Cinema and for Gallego and much much
more sign up at joinpakman.com subscribe
to the podcast subscribe to the YouTube
channel do the thing and we will see you
on the bonus show or back here tomorrow
foreign